♫ ♫
>> PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE OUR
BIPARTISAN, BICAMERAL
NEGOTIATIONS ON DEFENSE SPENDING
ANOTHER PRIORITIES HAVE YIELDED
A SIGNIFICANT AGREEMENT.
NO ONE WOULD SUGGEST IT’S
PERFECT BUT WE WORKED HARD TO
FIND COMMON GROUND AND STAY
FOCUSED ON SERVING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> THE BUDGET DEAL DOESN’T HAVE
EVERYTHING DEMOCRATS WANT.
IT DOESN’T HAVE EVERYTHING
REPUBLICANS WANT, BUT IT HAS A
GREAT DEAL OF WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT.
>> I AM HEARTENED CONGRESS
RECOGNIZES THESE SOBERING EFFECT
OF BUDGETARY UNCERTAINTY ON
AMERICA’S MILITARY AND ON THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO PROVIDE FOR
OUR NATION’S DEFENSE.
>> Shannon: WE BRING IN THE
PANEL TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
BYRON YORK, THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
A.B. STODDARD, ASSOCIATED EDITOR
AT REAL CLEAR POLITICS.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST."
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU.
BYRON, THERE’S A LOT OF MONEY
FOR DEFENSE, DOMESTIC MONEY.
WHAT IS IT DOING TO THE BUDGET
DEFICIT IN THE LONG TERM?
MAKES THE BUDGET FIGURE AND THE
DEFICIT BIGGER.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
WHAT IT SHOWS IS A LOT OF
LAWMAKERS DON’T WANT ANOTHER
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN AND THEY ARE
TIRED FROM STAGGERING FROM ONE
CONTINUING RESOLUTION TO
ANOTHER.
THE GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO
SHUTDOWN IN THREE WEEKS AND THEN
TO ACCEPT IT OUT OF THAT AGAIN.
THERE’S NO WAY TO DO IT.
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN WANTING TO
GET MORE MONEY FOR DEFENSE.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET A LOT MORE
MONEY FOR DEFENSE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN WANTING MORE
MONEY FOR DOMESTIC SPENDING.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET BACK.
AND THE BUDGET HAWKS ARE GOING
TO GET MAD.
THEY WILL STAGE PROTEST VOTES.
AND THEN EVERYBODY WILL MAKE A
DEAL.
>> Shannon: A.B., THIS IS
SOMETHING REPUBLICANS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT FOR DECADES.
THEY DON’T LIKE GOVERNMENT TOOK
UP BIG GOVERNMENT AND SPENDING
LOTS OF MONEY.
>> I LIKE THE PARTIES COMING
TOGETHER.
WHERE THIS ENDS UP THAT WE HAVE
NO IDEA.
THE PARTIES NEVER AGREE ON
FISCAL DISCIPLINE.
THEY AGREE ON SPENDING MORE.
WHEN IT GETS TOO HOT IN THE
ROOM, THEY GO, LET’S THROW MONEY
ON IT LET GO.
THAT’S THE MAKINGS OF A DEAL.
THE SUPER COMMITTEE OF 2011 WAS
A JOKE.
LEAD TO A SEQUESTER.
NOW THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE ANY
SEQUESTER.
NO SPENDING CUTS BECAUSE THEY
CAN’T AGREE ON WHERE IT SHOULD
BE SHRUNK.
IT’S GOING TO BE TOUGH FOR
REPUBLICANS POLITICALLY.
THEY WANT TO TURN OUT THEIR BASE
OF SUPPORT IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
VOTERS ARE HAPPY ABOUT THE TAX
REFORM BILL BUT IT AFFECTED THE
DEFICIT.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
A TWO YEAR OF TIME WHERE THEY
ELECT THE BUDGET BUST MORE
AND IT’S GOING -- IT’S VERY
FRUSTRATING TO FISCAL HAWKS.
THEY WILL BE OVERRULED AND A
DEAL WILL BE MADE.
IT’S AN ISSUE OF THE GRASSROOTS
LEVEL BECAUSE IT’S WHAT THEY
PROMISED THEY WOULD ATTEND TO.
>> Shannon: >> NOT JU.
FOR TWO YEARS TO GET AN EXTRA
150 BILLION.
IT CREATES A NEW SPENDING LEVEL.
EVERYTHING LOADS BASED OFF THAT.
TALK ABOUT THAT TAX CUTS OVER
TEN YEARS.
IT’S GOING TO WORK OUT TO BE THE
SAME THING.
BIPARTISANSHIP IS A GREAT WAY TO
BUST DEFICITS AND INCREASE DEBT.
>> Shannon: I KNOW YOU THINK
SCHUMER CAME OUT PRETTY GOOD IN
THIS DEAL.
>> THIS TYPE OF SPENDING IS
SERVING HIM WELL.
ALSO BEING ABLE TO GET OUT OF AN
IMMIGRATION DEAL AT THE SAME
TIME.
I THINK HE UNDERSTANDS THE
NUMBERS ARE BAD FOR DEMOCRATS
WITH IMMIGRATION AND HE WAS ABLE
TO AVOID THAT AND GET SPENDING.
GOOD FOR HIM.
NOT GOOD FOR FISCAL
CONSERVATIVES OR PEOPLE WHO CARE
ABOUT THE FISCAL HEALTH OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> FOR A LOT OF REPUBLICANS,
THIS PRESIDENT DOESN’T REALLY
CARE ABOUT FISCAL DISCIPLINE ALL
THAT MUCH BUT HE ONE OF THIS
DEAL.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS GOING TO BE
OKAY WITH THAT.
PRESIDENT WILL CAMPAIGN WHATEVER
CANDIDATES IT WOULD HELP AS WE
APPROACH NOVEMBER.
THERE’S REALLY NO PROBLEM WITH
IT.
THE BIG THING IS THERE IS NO
DACA IN IT.
DONALD TRUMP SEES THAT AS A
VICTORY AND A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
ON THE LEFTIST BASED SEE IT AS A
LOSS BECAUSE THEY HAVE GIVEN UP
LEVERAGE ONCE MORE AND IT HAS A
DEBT CEILING CLAUSE WHICH IS
GOING TO GET THE DEBT CEILING
PAST NOVEMBER SO NOBODY CAN USE
THE DEBT CEILING FOR LEVERAGE.
THIS IS A WIN FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Shannon: IT’S GOT TO GO TO
THE HOUSE AND THERE ARE GOING TO
BE CRITICS WHO ARE UNHAPPY ABOUT
IT.
>> YEAH.
THEY’RE GOING TO HAVE TO WORK
SOME MORE WONDERS BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS BECAUSE THAT’S RIGHT.
THE HOUSE HAS THE FREEDOM CAUCUS
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO STAND UP   D
OBJECT TO THIS ON BUDGETARY
REASONS.
AND THEN YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE
THE LAST THING WE DIDN’T GET AN
AGREEMENT ON A DACA FIX SO WE
CAN’T VOTE FOR ANYTHING.
AGAIN, I DON’T KNOW.
I THINK YOU CAN PROBABLY SEE A
SITUATION WHERE DONALD TRUMP
GETS ON THE PHONE AND BEN’S
ENOUGH YEARS AND MINDS AMONG
THOSE FISCAL HAWKS IN THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS TO GET THE
NUMBERS TO WHERE THEY NEED TO
BE.
AND THEN THEY LOSE THE LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS ON THE HOUSE SIDE BUT
THEY GET IT THROUGH.
MAYBE THAT’S OPTIMISTIC BUT
THAT’S WHERE I STAYED GOING.
>> Shannon: WE SAW
NANCY PELOSI TAKE TO THE FLOOR
FOR EIGHT HOURS.
MOMENTS AGO WE SAW A PICTURE OF
THE SHOES SHE WAS WEARING.
I HAVE TO TAKE MY HAT OFF TO
HER.
WEARING THOSE STILETTOS THE
ENTIRE TIME.
>> LONG SPEECHES ARE ADMIRABLE.
HE USED TO SEE IT IN THE HOUSE
AND SENATE.
PEOPLE HAVE STOPPED TALKING
THROUGH ISSUES OR ADVOCATING FOR
THEIR BELIEFS.
IT IS ADMIRABLE TO SEE SOMEONE
GIVING AN EIGHT HOUR SPEECH.
BUT IT DOES FEED INTO THE
PROBLEMS DEMOCRATS HAVE WHICH IS
THEY CARE MORE ABOUT NONCITIZENS
THAN CITIZENS AND THEY ARE
WILLING TO DO A LOT OF WORK ON
BEHALF OF NONCITIZENS WITHOUT
THINKING THROUGH THE PEOPLE WHO
WILL ACTUALLY BE ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE FOR THEM.
>> Shannon: THEY WANT SOME OF
THOSE FOLKS TO BE ELIGIBLE.
>> THE PROBLEM FOR PELOSI’S HILL
OUT OF HER BASE THIS      THINKS
JUST A SHOW.
NICE TO GO OUT AND GIVE AN EIGHT
HOUR SPEECH.
BUT YOU ARE JUST GOING TO AGREE
TO IT AT CRUNCH TIME.
THIS WAS A VERY, VERY LONG
VIRTUE SIGNALING FROM THE
MINORITY LEADER TELLING THE KEY
CONSTITUENT GROUPS SHE’S ON
THEIR SIDE EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE
ABOUT TO PUT DACA OFF TO THE
SIDE.
>> Shannon: LET’S TALK ABOUT
THE TEXTS PUT TOGETHER BY
SENATOR RON JOHNSON.
SOME OF BEEN RELEASED BETWEEN
PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE.
ONE OF THEM COMES ON
SEPTEMBER 2, 2016, SAYS MAKING,
TALKING POINTS FOR DIRECTOR
COMEY.
THERE WAS SPECULATION IT WAS
ABOUT THE HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION BUT THERE IS TALK
ABOUT THE RUSSIA POTENTIAL
POLLUTION INVESTIGATION.
IT’S RAISING MORE QUESTIONS AND
CRITICISM.
>> "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTED THIS AFTERNOON THEY
THINK FROM THEIR REPORTING THEY
HAVE CONCLUDED THAT
SENATOR JOHNSON IS INCORRECT AND
THAT THIS WAS A PRESIDENT ASKING
FOR INTELLIGENCE ON RUSSIAN
MEDDLING BECAUSE HE WAS GOING TO
FACE PUTIN IN PERSON IN THE
COMING DAYS.
I THINK PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE HAVE HAD THEIR -- EVERYONE
IS MADE UP THEIR MINDS ABOUT
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
WE DON’T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION, WITH THE INSURANCE
POLICY IS THAT THEY DISCUSSED IN
ANDY’S OFFICE, THE OFFICE OF
ANDREW MCCABE.
HE HAS SINCE LEFT, DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR.
THERE ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS BUT
I’VE A GUY WILL GO WITH
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTED ON THIS UNTIL FURTHER
NOTICE.
>> THAT’S INTERESTING ABOUT
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTING.
PEOPLE THOUGHT I HAD TO DO WITH
THE HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION, LEARNING IT’S
ABOUT TRUMP-RUSSIA MEDDLING IS
MORE INTERESTING.
ONE WAS OBAMA FIRST BRIEFED?
WHEN DID YOU LEARN ABOUT THE
DOSSIER?
A NORMAL PRESS CORPS WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN THOSE ANSWERS.
THIS IS A TINY PART OF A LARGE
SCANDAL.
ALSO NEWS ABOUT SENATORS
GRASSLEY AND GRANDMA.
A CRIMINAL REFERRAL OF
CHRISTOPHER STEELE THAT VERIFIED
A LOT OF WHAT THE NUNES MEMO
SAID.
THE USE OF THE UNVERIFIED,
SALACIOUS DOSSIER.
THEY DIDN’T TELL THE COURT IT
WAS BOUGHT FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC.
HAVING THE CORROBORATION FROM
THE HOUSE AND SENATE THAT THERE
ARE PROBLEMS WITH THESE
SURVEILLANCE AUTHORITIES IS BIG
NEWS.
>> Shannon: WHY DO YOU THINK
THE MEMO DIDN’T GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION YESTERDAY.
THEY SENT US FOR CRIMINAL
REFERRAL IN JANUARY BUT WHAT
THEY ASKED THE FBI DO IS TO
UNREDACTED AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
PREPARED BY DIFFERENT PEOPLE AND